who spends more money on the opposite  gender guys men are women obviously men  yeah yeah  it depends actually  it depends actually it's very dependent  it depends on you  it depends it depends  she was earning way more  and he was no job he had no job at all  he was like doing drugs you know like  player left what is she doing like  exactly  i'm sorry  and he was good looking you know and  then there's  this and that and there's the fun of it  i agree with her there's a lot of people  i know that are in that situation  exactly there's a lot of people  there that's rare though that's rare  usually  it's not it's not that rare  how many times have you seen a guy yeah  in a passenger seat no  oh on the average relationship the guy's  gonna be paying for the for the for the  dates he's gonna be  like men earn more than women  those guys are in the top 10 15 of like  looks wise that's the only reason they  can get away with it